però se bisognasse minuti questo
nuovissimo video di come stiamo già
questo un gioco un nuovo a beneficio
delle macchine che devono imparare col
una roba strana beh nuovo comunque buona
visione
politini se vi piace bravo ma sembra
senza però occhio che colora di donna
però bravissimo era bella però era bella
veramente bella ma io ho cambiato e
l'austria hai cambiato lassisti che ho
visto visto che non è nè quella del fas
battagliano all'xbox di una delle auto
che si utilizza di più che non mi sono
minimamente quale dai dribbling uno
bellissimo infatti manda alto tanto ha
insegnato e sei stato bravissimo
questo in coda scempio un vero torno
torno torno nobel che bello bravi
bello bello bello bello ha la faccia da
metti la faccia a faccia previsto bravi
ora è invece me la mette non si mette al
favi non si vedeva che quello butta
dentro unità perché ho avuto paura che
lui l'ha toccata leggermente sia
toccando grande la propria messa quindi
non poteva fare altro sia la prova
incornata subito quello seguito è sicuro
ho fatto cose però la palla arriva da lì
occhio che tira madonna vai vado
problema ma nessuno ma che brutto a palo
non esisti mannaggia bella la ripartenza
di step bellissimo lo esploso no non ho
tirato come volevo sul prodotto sono ben
fatto tantissimo ma questi si fanno i
passaggi della vita donna va bene dai
dai dai che questa doppia vince dai è
stato che mi diceva che buttava
anticipato ma mai era una burla
ci ho provato occhio che si sa passano
bravissimo
allora ho provato al massimo della
velocità vai
eccolo eccolo imprese col preside ci
siamo perplessi in ci siamo
ora che ha scavalcato vai e il momento
aia scusa perché lo voi ma la turbo però
è certo certo ma non per le palle e gli
ho rotto le palle vai un rimpallo no
vabbè poi vi spiega come la pinza tutta
palla
devo fare così se non lo si è fatto bene
bene bene avere occhio no e ha mai
venduti bari non ci arriva ci arriva da
chagall ci credo ma come è possibile
lui lascerà di patty è fatta non ho
detto io so io bellissimo
[Risate]
bravo bellissima dove maniera prematura
e già puntato da un'ora e mezzo
all'inizio era tutto deciso
bellissimo va bene 4 a 3 casco
l'ostacolo ha tirato il joystick sul
monitor la sua attenzione che li teniamo
augurato anche qualcosa di molto brutto
0 ma il tiro che non è male ma cosa che
cosa tolto che come la notte brava
sì che si basano incredibili attenzione
attenzione bella vista veramente brutta
loro ok belgio pallone pallonetto
fastidioso infatti vai vai vai vai vai
non ci sei cairo storto occhio occhio
bravissimo proprio dai bravissimo mamma
mia che si rimanda che suda bravissimi
oggi in dribbling tanta ma la macchina
se come agevola tanto anche l'uomo punti
è molto adatto al secondo me il
dribbling bella bellissima è la nuova la
nuova e bellissima
attenzione a me sembra relativi è
bellissimo è no ma questa è la prima
volta che la faccio non ho mai fatto gol
no forse sì forse no bellissimo la cia
il palo eccola lì come la battezziamo la
mappa nuova proprio loro prova parti un
cross
sì sì pressiamo perché questi il
presidio soffronto lo dico io io penso
io
eccola ci sei non ci sei non andare in
porta fortissimo eccola carcerato non ci
credo le entrate ma tanto ti prego
togliere ancora troppo guarda abbiamo
più guarda o entravamo nel codice di
programmazione o non poteva pagarla st
palla dovevamo voi deve programmare il
gioco abbiamo fatto di tutto di non si
sa neanche come entrata proprio il gioco
detto abela facciamo trapasso facciamo
che trapassa gli avversari se non entra
e cia trapassati perché se non entrava
proprio eli eli ritorno turno o di tutti
i prodotti tre major
va beh certo sì certo va bene dai va
bene da allora ditelo subito se dobbiamo
lasciargli la jolie già subito ma hanno
pagato quando hanno pagato il george e
dai ma che cacchio è terminare inbal mi
è rimbalzata malattia da dosso è affatto
una micro micro pallone terribile si
sente così incredibile questo risultato
veramente non bugiardo di più questo è
veramente orribile si stava ripuntando
pensione attenzione lo tolgo fosse
riuscito l'ho tolto notato il toto noti
tra l'altro fregato la messa riguarda
vai mai mai mai se non segno questa
cambio cercato veramente di toglierli
tutte le maniere ha funzionato
quello che la prende col mio
massima attenzione non derby è bravo che
gli ato fastidio perfetto primo aver
trovato linea
vado lì attenzione la metto dentro un
tocchetto troppo un po devo stopparla
non male
riguardo io sono imposto nel cuore non
ci sono ci sono perfetto yacht o la
contenzione che ripartono arriva la
giovane è mia fuori mi ha fregato turbo
6 occhio mi tocca tantissimo bravo ok a
prato stanno provando ad esplodere sia
comparsi tutto il tempo per queste cose
queste cose questa cosa macchietta non
ricordo un ricordo
okay quanto tocco ci serve né buono
bravo giorno vado a tanta gente ci ho
provato in anticipo loeb ha un po lui lo
won pato non so se non si trattava
azioni armate il mente impazzito va bene
vai e non è venuto lui attenzione però
madonna sto con tra ordinaria e stato un
casino è sì o con quale vanno bene va la
vita immeritata per questi qua
mamma mia tocca la non è un poeta aveva
con la presa anche al lontano un
chilometro della presa uguale di michele
parti ci ho provato
contenitore per un altro tocco è certo
mi hanno pompato è niente da peccato
meritavamo noi questo con tutto il
rispetto a quest'anno stamani tavolo
ragazzi superare in questo gioco mai
visto prima perché ci sia piaciuto e noi
io ringrazio lo staff anticipato al
video procedere celermente vi piace non
ci vediamo al prossimo video come sempre
è un bacino
ciao ragazzi
[Musica]